[Music]
in Claudian courier news Oh career or
career career loading she says me mmm
this one is very spicy submitted by what
sucks
Oh wet socks matter what school a couple
yeah the lot the roads during rainy days
they flood like crazy so whenever you
cross the street you just have no choice
but to either like jump and probably
fall on your ass or just get your socks
wet or the cars drive by and splash if
you tell me why the [ __ ] all right
junior year I was walking home and I
used to live right across the street
from couple I spent the whole day trial
so proud of myself I had umbrellas and
[ __ ] my sorority got this card dated on
[ __ ] purpose Rona's about to cross
the street just weld like in the cartoon
across the street from my house I was
personal you're out there I hope you get
[ __ ] but that's never happened to me
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
cartoon she doesn't really happen to me
it happened to me I [ __ ] him and walking
to school I slipped on a banana peel
once oh my god did you also walk by
ability and a piano felony right my life
is a joke you guys like I slipped I
didn't fall but I caught myself I was
like did I really just [ __ ] happen
did you ever run and their legs rotated
but you never went anywhere
no insulting god this school teaching
you how to be a Korean pop star okay so
let's go those schools like that though
yeah that's their career right in Korea
but this one's in NYC we actually know a
handful of like kpop in the making
people they [ __ ] hate it they're like
we're [ __ ] heaps yeah that's where
it's very like step 1:45 plastic
surgeries step two no cell phone I've
heard of you can't it take a cold dudes
in the contractor step four we control
what you eat just dancing all day long
five your relationships forget about it
but like they get famous but they barely
make money that's it sucks because like
the label guilt trips in because as they
try to leave their label they're like we
invested all this time into you and then
this is how you show things you just
like look crazy it's like the opposite
you know how here managers make 15% out
their artists they make that little bit
yeah but uh my buddy who is a kpop star
he started his own label and I guess
he's doing well for himself so that was
a smart move so now he's the one taking
advantage but it's smart though like he
left I think I'm not really into this
whole kpop thing but he's not with that
label anymore and he has its own label
gochu Records gosh
David got your records there's a school
in New York this is actually a branch of
a chain that was founded in South Korea
back in 2008 he's like why a branch a
branch of a chain Brett that's how they
wrote it in the article a branch of a
chain I don't know
so it's called born star training center
and it opened two years ago and it's New
York's first kpop school what's the
tuition
that's a good question I'll show you I
want to know how much that is
me too but because there was this one
video where they interviewed students
and they were saying like it's really
hard because they have to work multiple
jobs to be able to afford this goal but
that they're passionate about it oh and
then when you get big you get big over
there or you get big over here just a
training part and you just don't do it
no they do they do set up auditions for
like
recruitment so it's not even guaranteed
they train you and you still got
audition so for sure Wow so do they have
like oh I just mentioned they have
classes just to teach the girls how to
do that's [ __ ] poses on their faces
just like all those hands because they
can do like 20 of them at a time
Wow yeah they teach they're saying that
if they also teach Korean because a lot
of their students are not even Korean
that's true yeah and so they they also
they teach Korean they teach dance
singing how to act
modeling all that stuff so I'm sure you
guys a quick clip quick clip say that
three times really kpop makes me very
sad yeah
here we go but what we're trying to do
here is kind of bring that training
system how it is in Korea how these
Korean companies can cultivate an artist
like BTS and try to bring that realistic
thing to New York it's not just talent
the Korean company looks at the entire
package as a whole whereas the US market
and other you know markets are a little
less like that they really they look at
the towel at first and then they try to
you know they will work from there we
represent someplace amongst is hustling
hustling New York where it's like an
incan well yeah you can't dream a little
more you know but work is work the job
is a job just not like you're like they
say like their slaves man I don't know
if it's the same with this guy I don't
know what he's doing but then and then
even if you go to these schools or like
the type of training that they put like
that they put these k-pop stars into
it's like you can spend X amount of
years into it and your night in
guaranteed debut well this is kind of
like film school or whatever school I
think it's just bringing the kpop work
ethic into America exactly yeah
and then they're like well if you you
know this is what it's like to dance
your ass off work your ass off and you
know put together a group or whatever
none of us can be kpop stars here
because we're so good in vulgar will
[ __ ] up immediately
oh the PR aspect oh yeah ideally a [ __ ]
up sword like that one I don't member
who he recorded a snapchat and someone
in the background in the room was he
that he was in was talking about weed
and his fans went crazy and he got
chopped from his label immediately
because someone else in the video was
something that we'd we don't get [ __ ]
immediately wow I think I would be a
great kpop star because I'll be sighs
friend
I already got afraid that looks like psy
80 I think you'd be a great kpop star in
North Korea yeah
both kpop stars actually you should do
the North Korean pop star group
have you seen those creepy-ass [ __ ]
like North Korean musical bands yes they
got like three year old kids that are
playing guitars and they're like oh you
mess up one note your family gets killed
yeah the fakest [ __ ] smiles and [ __ ]
[Music]
funny though I bet you anything that
same type of training regimen whether
you're North Korea or South Korea
Koreans have the same type of work ethic
and they apply that [ __ ] mm-hmm they
apply the same [ __ ] that's so sad you
know it's one of the creepiest things
you we should just show just show that
mother show that [ __ ] North Korean
children guitar children guitar banjo
yeah so while she looks for that I feel
like that yeah something about Asians
like they gotta suck the [ __ ] fun out
of everything that's fun it's like oh
music it's so beautiful and it's like
great right but they [ __ ] suck the
[ __ ] joy and passion out of [ __ ]
everything dude they'll suck that [ __ ]
out and it'll just make you work on it
until your [ __ ] legs break and then
they go now you can dance but there's no
heart in that [ __ ] but kpop is killing
it though here we go dude
[Music]
they're clean - yeah they're small cuz
they don't eat what you don't know is
they're like nine years old
that's insane how good they are [ __ ]
cute though
that little girl's gonna get beat up
they're [ __ ] that's a big smile man
[Music]
it's scary
children should never have precision
[Music]
children should never have be on point
they are really really good I'm sad
maybe I'm just jealous I'm just a
question would you guys rather be sorry
and have a lot of fun or be [ __ ]
amazing at something I'm sorry at
everything right not really like it that
I experienced that so like when I was
going to accordion classes I was able to
kill that [ __ ] no no I got into playing
accordion because this guy for
show-and-tell right he he was playing
the accordion and I was like dude the
accordion Oh Steve Urkel plays accordion
I want to play accordion so then I
begged my parents to take me to the
class I started taking lessons you could
never do wrong in this class you could
[ __ ] up you could be sorry there's kids
that don't practice they [ __ ] suck
and I'm looking at him like you guys
suck dick this sucks
yeah but it's still like everyone was
having a good time so I had a blast
every time I went to class it made me
want to practice I love it right my dad
on the other hand he would be my ass
every time I hit the wrong key or like I
don't learn fast enough or whatever it's
the Asian style teaching because of that
I [ __ ] hated piano didn't hate music
I just hated piano
same thing with me right cuz they don't
know how to just have fun like take the
[ __ ] you know like just have a little
fun with it learn I don't really start
learning violin school that you said at
school yeah I thought the music program
backing yeah yeah they took out the
music program when I was in 4th Kong Oh
Grady yeah it was no no more so they
brought it back a lot of parents don't
realize how bad they're [ __ ] up the
passion and children like for you the
cordoning accordion I [ __ ] do it I
used to read every single book in the
house I used to read so much and I got
some point where my grandparents were
annoyed it was like dude my parents
would have loved if I read right like
just shut up and read something feel
like you're not cleaning enough I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now
yeah it's weird
it was weird of [ __ ] hey you guys want
to stock any of us we'll go ahead down
to the description box below and you can
follow us on Instagram and all kinds of
stuff for more videos
[Music]